so far we have introduced many
classification metrics
next we'll present some popular
regression performance metrics
the most popular regression metrics are
mean absolute error
mae or mean squared error mse
the mean absolute error mae measures the
average of the absolute errors
that is the difference between the
prediction and the ground truth value
the mean squared error mse on the other
hand
measures the average of the squared
error mse is easier to work with because
the derivative of the square term is
linear
but mse will greatly affected by
outliers because of the square term as
well
on the other hand mae is more robust
against the outliers
but it's harder to work with because
this absolute value is not
differentiable
here are some visual illustrations the
x-axis is the grand truth value
and the y-axis is the prediction as the
amount of noise increases from left to
right
both mae and mse increase you can also
notice that mse increased a lot faster
because the square of error term